ça pouvait sembler si simple ou du moins
rassurant la promesse d'une place à bord
d'un vol d'évacuation de l'aéroport de
kaboul
et les derniers mètres pour franchir
cette marée humaine porté par la panique
et le désespoir ont été les plus
difficiles parcourir pour ce journaliste
afghan dans un
aussi
bas qu aimer appelons le abdul il n'est
pas autorisé à parler par le groupe de
presse étrangers pour lequel il
travaille et qui a orchestré son départ
de l'afghanistan avec une vingtaine de
ses collègues ce n'est qu'à leur
troisième tentative qu'ils ont pu avec
leur famille passé les contrôles des
talibans ceux des soldats qui gardaient
l'entrée de l'aéroport et tous et un
premier soupir de soulagement et rose
avec lui un frère travailler pour le
renseignement afghans un autre employé
au parlement du gouvernement en fuite
des parents qui subissaient les menaces
des talibans depuis déjà 10 ans dans sa
province natale les promesses des
talibans ne sont que des paroles dit il
aujourd'hui en sécurité à islamabad lui
a été témoin d'une toute autre image
s'il est donc en sécurité il n'est pas
en paix pour autant depuis son
évacuation ils ignorent complètement ce
qu'il l'attend son employeur promet de
faire des démarches auprès de plusieurs
pays mais il craint que sa famille
nombreuse ils sont seize au total ne
soit un frein pour ceux qui se sont
engagés à accueillir les afghans
vulnérables ce qu'il sait c'est que le
pakistan ne peut pas être une
destination finale et dont le reach
quand tu es béni les chômeurs go from
ibiza fera
officiellement le pakistan compte déjà 1
million 400 mille réfugiés afghans mais
selon les nations unies les autorités
pakistanaises se serait plutôt 3
millions d'afghans qui vivent au
pakistan certains depuis plusieurs
décennies et beaucoup d'entre eux dans
des camps de fortune comme celui ci sans
eau potable sans électricité tous ces
enfants sont nés ici au pakistan leurs
parents se plaignent d'être menacés
d'expulsion et harcelés par la police de
façon régulière mais pour chéraga arrivé
en traversant la frontière illégalement
il ya trois jours c'est au moins
sécurité motion
liban prétendent avoir changé devant les
caméras mais ce n'est que du spectacle
dit il ils ne savent pas écrire ou lire
de toute façon alors les messages des
dirigeants n'atteint pas les talibans
déroule inférieure ce que l'on voit
ce week end où
tout
ça il a longtemps travaillé comme
interprète aux côtés des journalistes de
l'agencé de la presse canadienne c'est
par la route rongé par la peur d'être
démasqué par les talibans qui l'a
rejoint le pakistan avec sa femme et ses
enfants de mort des neufs 30 i/s
virtuelle des
ordinateurs
munis
d'oreillettes la peur elle habite encore
même ici
les talibans ont le bras long surtout au
pakistan dit une position
a même présente à menzel
il a l'impression d'étouffer la tête
sous l'eau ce n'est qu'une fois au
canada qui a accepté de lui ouvrir ses
portes mais au plus vite plaît-il qu'il
pourra respirer de nouveau